whenever people ask me what kind of
games I like to play role-playing games
is generally my go-to response and
Bethesda's Elder Scrolls series is a
huge part of the reason why I've been
playing and replaying that series ever
since I first played morrowind as a kid
I love these games and that's a part of
the reason I've been so skeptical about
the Elder Scrolls online the next
installment into the epic saga has some
Elder Scrolls fans like me worried that
the move to the MMO format will make the
game lose out on what it's done so
successfully in the past if this new
game is gonna be any good it's going to
have to do a few things to prove itself
to its hardcore fans it may occasionally
be difficult to remember all the details
of all the quest lines you're involved
in at any one time in Skyrim but at the
end of the day there's a spectacular
heroic narrative there if you've played
your cards right chances are you've
ended up as the one and only dragon born
Archmage of winterhold
guild master of the Thieves Guild now
listen up the harbinger and then some
when you put them all together like that
it sounds really dumb but the one true
hero narrative that is being the best at
everything in Tamriel is a huge part of
the Elder Scrolls series very in life
the main complication with the Elder
Scrolls online now that the format is
massively multiplayer you're all of a
sudden faced with all these other people
who are all going to be the best in
Tamriel
and that soul one true hero crown is
threatened
obviously this already happened with
anybody who played Skyrim but with so
many other players around you're awfully
confronted with the reality that you
aren't all that special since an MMO
doesn't offer that appeal of being the
singular hero Elder Scrolls online needs
to offer the player something different
but still keep the classic heroic
narrative intact
while a memos have their own set of
funds on redefining hooks but those that
have additional hurdles to overcome when
it comes to turning the elderscrolls
into this kind of game Skyrim fans are
likely to come into the Elder Scrolls
online with certain expectations which
are difficult to emulate in an MMO for
example the graphics are a far cry from
even an unmodern Skyrim game the
animations leave loads to be desired and
the combat isn't going to be as tight
but the quality of questing will be one
of the biggest deciding factors for the
favour of gamers now not all MMO suffer
from this but there can certainly be an
overwhelming number of relatively
insignificant quests from relatively
insignificant NPCs for example gather
ten assorted carcasses from a certain
cave and return for a random reward the
Elder Scrolls online needs to prove that
it can still retain the memorable
characters and intriguing quest lines
from its parent franchise so far they
seem to be doing this well in cutscenes
but for Skyrim fans to stay interested
that needs to transfer quite clearly to
the core of the game alright so I think
it's about the time in this video where
I need to come out and say what we're
all thinking
basically the Elder Scrolls online needs
to not be [ __ ] Skyrim populated by jerks
who so often frequent multiplayer games
the Elder Scrolls online already needs
to be monumentally scaled down in
performance and graphics to function as
an MMO which is why competing with a
single-player RPG on that front is not
going to be an option it's never going
to be as pretty or immersive as Skyrim
the one thing it can do though is make
multiplayer mean something if
multiplayer is the crowning glory of
this title then it needs to be
intrinsically linked to the way players
approach their game the flaws in the one
true hero narrative could be mended by
the strong suggestion that you're
fighting for your faction and all your
guild the sense that you're a part of
something larger and not just one of 30
dudes exploring the same dungeon trying
to be the one true savor of Tamriel
really could be the thing that draws in
skyrim fans where we've had an alternate
take on last week's episode about Dark
Souls saying why the game is just so
amazing just try Dark Souls 1 and I
loved it until I had to replay the same
stretch a million times and just gave up
I admire
game and the difficulty is kind of
refreshing but I want to jump into a
game when I play not replay the same
pots over and over just a personal
preference definitely a great game
that's fair enough
Dark Souls can be easier to admire than
it is to love especially when you've
died a millimeter away from the next
bonfire for the hundredth time but as
these net points out in response Dark
Souls to try to remedy some of these
problems by reducing the number of
respawning enemies either way though I
think I'm inclined to agree with Tommy
c77 who writes last night I met a random
guy on Dark Souls 2 and we spent a few
hours helping each other out with bosses
talk about twenty attempts but we
finally beat the ancient dragon together
after figuring out all the bosses moves
and how to work effectively as a team
speaking as someone who got 100%
achievements on Dark Souls 1 I can
honestly say the struggle and torment is
worth it back to this week's topic let
me know whether you think Elder Scrolls
online has done enough to impress Skyrim
fans or whether you reckon the game will
find an audience outside of the original
franchise leave me all of your thoughts
and feelings in that comment section and
I'll see you next week